[Music]
hey
come on time to lay it out for those
little idiots
their 15 minutes is up
hey so what's the plan simple
we get in the club find the little [ __ ]
dressing room
do our thing delta thing is
i can't be seen not about to give him
any free
pr yeah pretty sure you gave him enough
already
burning truck was everywhere all the
sheets all the feeds
don't get smart tell me how we get
inside
look sometimes simplest is best we just
buy tickets
okay first you whacked
not about to let those [ __ ] make and
any off of me second
it's sold out cool we'll find a way in
anyway
let's look around
uh
down
[Music]
i got the best idea we'll give her a
present when we go to their show
[Music]
okay
come on help us out we left them inside
no can't try the main door they'll check
the list
yeah but by that time the holler
projectiles be on and out of whack
i'll have to recalibrate no way this
show starts on time
sayonara you're out cause ain't no way
we're taking the fall
[ __ ] all right go staple into your
[ __ ] foreheads next time will ya
thanks pal you just saved the show
recalibrate hollow projectors how do you
even know [ __ ] like that
past life work backstage for g-hung free
time japanese
learn some things how the [ __ ] finally
came in handy today
[Music]
tell him you were pregnant sure but he
can't opt out he's still paying off his
implants
oh it's not that bad they locked mine up
when diego was barely won
oh wait this is a special boy
from foundation organization
now we're gonna chat
who the [ __ ] are you the [ __ ] guy you
robbed
carry uridine carry sucks i ain't your
son
this ain't a meeting hey
[Music]
you'll do what he says now and then you
forget he was ever here
and if we don't don't and you can say
goodbye to your careers
right now simple as that harry son
we don't get it we have a deal
they said you loved us they said your
bedroom was full oh
hell no you hearing this the
[ __ ] are you on i'd sure like to try it
[Music]
okay seems like you don't get it i don't
give a [ __ ] what you thought
there is no deal and there will be no
deal
but you're my song on that stage you are
done in night city
it's a promise but we're going to bring
your rock into a new era
isn't that what you want rock you okay
let me tell you something it's been
claimed before but you actually did it
rock is dead and you killed it
congratulations
your manager contacted ours said you
wanted to work with us
listen harry son that cover is an
expression of our love for you
please let's work something out rock
might be dead
but carrie's blind if he can't see these
girls got potential
looks like the label [ __ ] you all
you're their pawns
they're playing you had enough of this
[ __ ] around
tell them the concert's off now
cancel the show yeah yeah just
do it we'll talk later
you're going to call those scop suckers
from msm and tell them you've changed
your mind about the cover
got it whatever you want carries on
and not a word about this to anyone
unless you want v to pay you another
visit
let's go
best not to leave together sure and
thanks
you don't take matters into your own
hands they'll squeeze you dry
chew you up and [ __ ] you out later